today on the matt walsh show the media
is falling all over itself to celebrate
simone biles for quitting she's the most
inspiring and courageous quitter
the world has ever seen they tell us but
i'm not so sure that i agree with this
redefinition of courage and our five
headlines including the pathetic
desperate and grotesque display put on
by the democrats during the january 6
hearing yesterday
also alexandria casa cortez who was not
in the capital
building that day now says that she was
afraid that she would be raped
that's what she said the cdc has also
reinstated the mask mandate but the
question is
whether anyone gives a damn about the
cdc's mandates at this point in our
daily cancellation
after a day filled with men crying on
camera we will discuss whether these
sorts of displays
should be welcomed in our society at all
all of that and more today on the matt
walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
now a quick word before we get started
from a new sponsor on the show
rex md you know a lot of guys i think uh
don't like going to the doctor
for really any reason at all uh but
especially if it's uh you know
it's something you don't want to talk to
a doctor about face to face that's what
rex rexmd is all about xmd.com
has fda approved generic viagra starting
at just two dollars per tablet and
delivered discreetly to your door
here's how it works just fill out a
brief survey and if appropriate you can
try a starter pack of generic viagra
starter packs are currently available to
new customers rexmd.com
has helped over 100 000 men get generic
viagra from the comfort of their home
there's no
co-pay there are no doctor office visits
and your shipping
is always free if you're looking for
generic viagra rexmd has made the
process
fast easy and uh also affordable
and uh you know takes the embarrassment
away from you so don't wait another
minute rexmd is now
offering starter packs of generic viagra
for new customers you can visit
rexmd.com walsh right now to get started
that's rex
r-e-x-m-d dot com slash walsh
from the way that olympic gymnast simone
biles is being praised this week you
might think that the decorated superstar
put on a heroic display during the team
competition in tokyo
uh yesterday and led her squad to a gold
medal
many prominent politicians like ayanna
pressley and corey bush and many others
have
made public statements applauding her
the white house press secretary
expressed
gratitude and support said we all should
express gratitude and support
for for simone biles deadspin gushed
over the
what they call the most impressive move
of her career
former olympians joined in the group hug
many athletes came out to support her
articles have been written
extolling her bravery declaring that her
achievements this week have sent a quote
powerful message to the world
cnn called her performance impactful the
new yorker described her
quote radical courage the new york times
talked about her champion mindset
she's been hailed for her strength and
for setting an amazing example
being a great athlete a great role model
all based on
what she did yesterday women's advocacy
groups have come to her
defense have thanked her for all that
she's done
it has been perhaps the most effusive
praise that has ever been heaped on a
quitter
and that's what simone biles did to earn
this exuberant applause after all she
gave up
after struggling in the qualifying
rounds and botching the first event
in the women's team finals biles decided
to withdraw from the meat
the best gymnast on the squad the leader
one of the most celebrated u.s olympic
athletes of all time
chose to abandon her team in the middle
of the finals
her teammates would finish second behind
russia while biles went on to receive
even more acclaim than a gold medal
would have earned her probably
there was some talk early on suggesting
that biles had been physically injured
but that was not the case
biles has since explained that she left
the competition in order to focus on her
mental health and her quote mindfulness
she complained that the olympics
haven't been fun this year she said
quote this olympic games i wanted to i
wanted it to be for myself when i came
in
and i felt like i was still doing it for
other people
returning to this theme later she said
that it's important to put
mental health first because if you don't
then you're not going to enjoy your
sport
she complained about the pressure that
she's been under here's a little more
from biles herself
explaining why she quit here she is
and it's been really stressful this
olympic games i think just as a whole
um not having an audience there are a
lot of different variables going into it
it's been
a long week it's been a long olympic
process it's been a long
year um so just a lot of different
variables and i think
we're just a little bit too stressed out
um
but we should be out here having fun and
sometimes that's not the case
i just felt like it would be a little
bit better to take a backseat
uh work on my mindfulness and i knew
that the girls would do
an absolutely great job and i didn't
want to risk the team a medal for
uh kind of my screw-ups because they've
worked way too hard for that so
i just decided that those girls need to
go in and do the rest of the competition
yeah i say um put mental health first
because
if you don't then you're not going to
enjoy your sport and you're not going to
succeed as much as you want to so it's
okay sometimes to even set out the big
competitions
to focus on yourself because it shows
how strong of a competitor and person
that you really are
now the people who wish to make excuses
for her have offered all kinds of
rationales
that biles herself has not offered there
have been lots of people online talking
about for example her sexual assault and
speculating that
somehow that might have contributed to
this but she has not once
cited that as a reason for her decision
and frankly it seems pretty disgusting
to inject that into this
uh discussion in hopes of bailing her
out when she has not brought it up
there are others saying that she was
essentially mentally incapacitated to
the point that
she physically couldn't perform the
moves but again that's not really what
she's saying
you can listen to what she's saying she
has talked more broadly about her mental
health
mentioned multiple times that she wasn't
having fun and said again
multiple times that she needed to focus
on herself
that's what she said those are her words
she explained
why she did this we don't need to
theorize about it she
told us now the question is whether
those are good reasons
they aren't now on one hand there's
nothing terribly surprising
about the reasons that she gave for
quitting people quit
things all the time and and they almost
always do it because the thing they're
quitting
is difficult and not very fun and
they're afraid of failing
this is the universal rationale of all
quitters
everywhere for all time i have quit
things myself for that reason
you have quit things for that reason
everyone has with no exceptions
in this case there's no doubt that the
difficult thing was very difficult
indeed
the pressure she experiences as a world
famous athlete on a global stage
must be quite burdensome on both an
emotional and physical level
and that's what makes quitting
understandable
the one thing that it cannot be is
admirable
now if simone biles here's the point
okay and i want everyone to try to
understand this
because a lot of people don't apparently
it's a very simple point
if simone biles had bailed on her team
as she did and apologized after the fact
um instead of saying well i need to
focus on myself and hey they can handle
it
if she had bailed her team apologized
after the fact and the public had
reacted in an appropriately sort of bun
bummed out kind of way to the news then
there wouldn't be much else to say on
the matter
it's hard to compete in the olympics
it's hard to live up to high
expectations
lots of people quit things when they're
hard again we all have it one time or
another
that's why when someone quits we
normally shake our heads and say
well that's a shame and then we move on
with our lives
nobody's suggesting that athletes who
quit ought to be tarred and feathered in
the street they might do that in china
maybe but um we're not saying that for
here
i'm not advocating that we put them in
the stockades in the middle of the town
square and throw tomatoes at them
that's not the point it's enough to be
disappointed and be done with it in fact
if that's how this had played out if she
had quit everyone was disappointed she
apologized
i wouldn't be saying a word about it i
wouldn't care personally
i wouldn't be talking about it
the problem is that now we are exhorted
not simply to understand why someone
quits but to actively
applaud them for doing it
what makes the simone bile story
troubling is not that the women's
gymnastics team had to settle for a
silver medal
but that our cultural powers that be
want us to celebrate
cowardice as always it's it's not enough
to merely tolerate
another person's decision or to be
compassionate towards their struggles
we are meant now to rise to our feet and
joyously
cheer what all people through history
and most people living in the world
today
would consider shameful and unfortunate
at least
it's radical courage is the the the
phrase being used to describe this
not understandable okay not
um not not something we should
sympathize with but radically
courageous to leave your team
in the lurch it's one thing to say
simone biles quit but let's have some
empathy empathy
if that was the message i would say sure
yeah sounds good
it is quite another to say simone biles
quit
isn't that so brave uh
no it's not it is
the definition of not brave
it may be human it may be relatable but
it's the opposite
of brave to be brave is to refuse to
quit precisely when most people would
that's why we admire people who
persevere because they are
rare quitters are a dime a dozen
cowardice isn't no short supply in our
world and it'll become even more common
now that we've rebranded it as courage
if we will be grant if if we will grant
to cowardice the rewards of courage
without any of the effort and sacrifice
it requires
why bother with courage at all
the many defenders of simone biles have
said that she's right a role model in
fact
for prioritizing her mental health above
all else
in the era of the psychological man when
there's nothing more important than the
self's opinion of itself
it is perhaps no surprise that we should
congratulate a woman
for explicitly putting herself before
her team and her country
i had to put myself first she says that
exactly explicitly
now we are celebrating athletes who do
that it used to be the exact opposite
that's not why you compete in a team
sport that's not why you
go to the olympics for your country if
you want to focus on yourself
you don't go you don't join the team
nobody is walking up to someone someone
sitting on a park bench
and saying why aren't you in the
olympics right now you selfish bastard
no because it's not a requirement but if
you are taking on that responsibility
then you're not supposed to put yourself
first that is the duty the
responsibility that you
have assumed for yourself
oh but mental health right
you're not allowed to say any of this no
because because the magic phrase the
magic term
the get out of jail free card mental
health has been used
that is now the shield meant to insulate
us from all criticism
oh you think you can criticize me for a
decision i made
well you can't because it helped my
mental health
the highest virtue now is the pursuit of
your own mental well-being
courage is now the avoidance
of mental anguish which is to say that
courage is now the exact
opposite of what it has always been and
what it actually is
still now today and yet still
you have to wonder how consistently the
new moral code would even be applied
would tom brady receive
such a worshipful reaction if he left in
the third quarter of a playoff game
because he wasn't having fun and needed
to work on his mindfulness
can you imagine that you can't it's
unthinkable because it would never
happen
never has happened you can't imagine
tom brady in the third quarter
of a playoff game or really this is the
super bowl
this is the this is the super bowl for
the for this sport i mean more than the
super bowl because this happens only
once every four years as opposed to
super bowl which happens every year
especially if you're tom brady and
you've been in like 10 of them but um
can you you can't imagine tom brady
third quarter of the super bowl
uh going to his coach and saying i gotta
sit out
what do you mean you gotta sit are you
injured no no i i i you know i gotta get
him
i'm not in the right head space right
now and i gotta work on myself
nobody would accept that sure there have
been cases of of sulking professional
athletes leaving the field or the court
a few seconds early
because they were frustrated and sad
during a bad loss we've seen this move
from lebron james for example perhaps
the greatest sulker
in all of sports um there are usually a
few people willing to defend this kind
of behavior from male athletes but
they've never been celebrated like a
returning war hero
the way simone biles has been and naomi
osaka before her
in fact i was arguing this point with a
sports writer on twitter last night and
he
in an attempt to defend biles brought up
the fact that scottie pippen
uh former chicago bulls player in the
1994 nba playoffs
sat out the final seconds of the game
because he was mad
that he wasn't going to get the ball
see that the guy was saying to me he
what are you saying to me see
here's an example of a male athlete
quitting on his team
well yeah it is in a very different
situation
in this case he was mad that he wasn't
giving he wanted the pressure on him and
he wasn't getting it and so he was mad
and he quit but he did quit on his team
that's true
but what happened to scottie pippen
he was universally reviled for that
everyone
everywhere criticized him to this day he
is criticized
and for good reason i've never heard
anyone call him brave or congratulate
him
for prioritizing his mental health
this is a privilege reserved only for
female athletes
at present that might change though
maybe one day we'll we'll celebrate both
male and female quitters
maybe we're fast approaching a time when
the greatest athletes will be those who
manage to feel the best about themselves
while competing at that point we won't
need it to perform
you know they won't need to perform any
athletic feats at all they can just
every sport will be them sitting in a
circle
and whispering sweet nothings to
themselves
everyone wins in the end may not make
for much of a spectator sport but at
least we will know that nobody's mental
health has been damaged
now let's get to our five headlines
you've probably heard in the news uh or
you've just seen
seen it around around town all these
help wanted signs
there are a lot of companies that are
looking for
help they're they're looking for
employees and uh
it's always difficult to find qualified
applicant it's especially difficult now
and that's why if you haven't tried if
you're a business owner if you're an
employer and you haven't tried zip
recruiter yet
now is the time to try ziprecruiter.com
walsh is where you need to go so you
could try this for free
zip recruiter doesn't wait to get for
great candidates to find you
okay this is not a passive process of
kind of throwing
the needle out into the haystack and
hoping that someone finds it
zip recruiter finds them for you when
you post a job on zip recruiter it gets
sent
out to over a hundred top job sites with
one click to increase your chances of
reaching top talent
then zip recruiters powerful matching
technology scans thousands of resumes to
find people with the right skills and
experience
for your job and actively invites them
to apply again this is an active process
not a passive one that's the most
important thing
so if you want to uh to do this which
which you should this is the way to find
uh the right applicant for you start
finding great candidates today when you
try zip recruiter for free just go to
this
exclusive web address that's
ziprecruiter.comwalsh
once again ziprecruiter.com w-a-l-s-h
zip recruiter
the smartest way to hire a couple of
reminders uh if you want to help this
show out
the best thing you can do is first of
all subscribe
on apple or spotify leave a five star
review
share the podcast with your friends uh
and i
i in fact demand
that you do this right now do it
subscribe and leave a five-star review i
will not take no for an answer
also by the way i've got a new uh
newsletter uh that
we just launched a few weeks ago and
it's free and
the great thing is it takes just a few
seconds to sign up mattwalchreport.com
we got a fancy url and everything
set up for you you just go to uh
mattwallsreport.com put your email
address in
and um i will send it over to the nsa
and no i'll what i'll do is i'll send
you the newsletter which you'll get once
a week and it's free to sign up and it
just takes a second
um you must do both of these things
immediately or face severe consequences
now i just have to think of what the
consequences will be because i got
nothing
i'm now in the predicament that you know
you find yourself in as a parent when
you make a threat and realize that you
can't back it up
which which does happen it's like it's
like you're you're uh you know you're
driving you're like eight hours into a
car trip on vacation
and the kids are acting up and you say
hey you two knock it off or i'm gonna
turn this car around and we're going
home
one more time and then you think oh well
actually i'm not gonna do that i can't
do that we spent thousands on this
vacation already
they really have me over a barrel right
now i guess there's nothing i can do
anyway i will think i will think of a
consequence just so you know
um all right let's go to
let's we'll start with this the january
6 committee held its first hearing
yesterday there was um for one thing
lots of crying
all of it fake and we'll have a little
bit more about the crying later on in
the daily cancellation because you
already know
that a bunch of men can't get up there
and cry on camera all day
without getting cancelled on this show
so that that has to happen that was a
foregone conclusion
aside from the crying though um some
capital police officers were were
brought on stage
and yes i used the word stage here
purposefully
brought on stage to tell their stories
and uh for the first time
this you'll notice this is pretty
unusual
especially from democrats these are
these capital police officers
these are the only police officers that
the democrats care about or have ever
cared about
the only police officers they've ever
shown any concern for usually
they're going out there and saying that
police officers are deranged
racist psychopathic lunatic serial
killers
who are hunting and murdering innocent
black men
that's that's that's how democrats spend
most of their time
and they're trying to defund police
departments and
actively make the job less safe for
police officers all across the country
make their job more difficult less safe
and it's also the democrats who have
made this into a situation where if
you're a police officer
and you have to use deadly force
against a criminal suspect a you know
a violent perp if you have to if you are
forced
by that person to use deadly force you
know that your life is over
potentially your freedom is now on the
line
because of these very same democrats who
are now putting on this big
display of caring about police officers
they back the blue all right but ver
in a very specific set of circumstances
they back the blue in the dc capital
um uh when when the rioters are
right-wingers
and that's it and of course and of
course when
uh it's it's not only that you know the
other factor here is that
these police officers are protecting
them
okay so yes police officers who protect
the you know from the perspective of
these democrat politicians if you're a
police officer and you protect me
well then obviously i support you you
have a very important job we don't want
to defund you
we don't want to take your weapons away
you know we want more of you in fact
we'll militarize the whole damn city
because protecting us that is so
important
now protecting the average peon on the
street
the guy who owns the liquor store in
downtown minneapolis or seattle or
wherever portland
or atlanta or detroit or baltimore
who cares about that guy yeah bernie's
place to the ground
who cares so
um very specific set of circumstances
obviously we have not seen any of the
police officers who
who uh dealt with the blm rioters and
there are so many examples we could pull
i mean let's just take one example
there was uh the the video um
and i don't remember which there are so
many cities that all bleeds together
um if you know you'll pardon the
expression
in in one of these cities there was a
video
of a police officer getting
uh hit over the head with a brick by
a blm rioter in fact there are multiple
videos of that happening in multiple
cities
i just have one in particular in mind
are we are we going to see him that
police officer are we going to see him
on capitol hill
are we going to see any demo are we
going to see adam schiff crying
over the trauma that that man has
clearly suffered have they checked in on
him
do they care are they wondering
obviously not they do care about
this guy though officer dunn was one of
the officers who
spoke at the hearing and he made some
rather striking claims let's listen
one woman in a pink mega shirt yelled
you hear that guys this voted for joe
biden
then the crowd perhaps around 20 people
joined in screaming boo
no one had ever ever
called me while wearing the uniform of a
capitol police officer
in the days following the attempted
insurrection
other black officers shared with me
their own stories of racial abuse on
january
6th one officer told me
he had never and in his his entire 40
years of life
been caught in to his face and that
streak ended on january 6.
yet another black officer later told me
he had been
confronted by insurrectionists in the
capital
who told him put your gun down
and we'll show you what kind of you
really are
um now i don't know much of anything
about this man officer dunn
[Music]
um i don't mean to besmirch his
reputation but i am not prepared to
believe
anything that he just said um just based
on the words themselves
and that that by the way is is that
that's the situation that we're in now
um because there are there have been so
many
false claims of this type that have been
made
and very often in politically convenient
circumstances
as this one is
so if it weren't for that
if these claims were only ever made
credibly or most of the time were made
credibly and usually confirmed
then you know after you give people the
benefit of doubt but that's that that's
just
most of the time when we hear claims
like this that it ends up being not true
so no matter who you are making the
claim i how can i simply believe it
now there were a lot of people there
obviously there were tons of cameras
from you know uh all
people holding cameras uh security
cameras
this is this is this is the nation's
capital this is dc
this is the u.s capitol building cameras
everywhere
one would assume so has there been
any video footage of that that's come
out have we seen any video footage
and he's not he's not saying that one
person called him the n-word he's saying
that
a whole crowd of people were chanting it
do we have any video footage of that
with all of the cameras all over the
place has that has that footage come out
this to me seems it's awfully similar to
the original reports from the media
claiming that um officer siknik was
beat to death with a fire extinguisher
and this was reported people were
claiming that this had happened
the media was reporting it as a fact and
i said at the time when the reports
first came out
that hey well hang on a second
you're telling me an officer was beat to
death in the middle of our nation's
capital and there's no video of it
nothing well it turns out that didn't
happen that was simply
a lie it was made up it was a media
fabrication officer sicknick we know
did tragically die but he died of of of
of a health crisis that was that was not
directly related to the rise he was not
killed by a writer which is why no
rioter has been charged with his murder
because he wasn't murdered
now um obviously calling someone a
horrible
name is not nearly as bad as beating
someone to death but even so
you would still expect for this to be
caught on camera for there'll be some
footage of it and we've gotten no
footage whatsoever we've seen no footage
of this
uh so until
footage is made available or we get some
kind of evidence i'm i
can't believe that
uh speaking of things that i really
cannot believe alexandria ocasio-cortez
was uh interviewed for kind of a
documentary by uh
that cnn was putting together and this
is an unreleased documentary for
whatever reason was never released
never saw the light of day project
veritas james o'keefe's outfit
they got a hold of this thing and they
released it
and um the whole thing you know it's
it's it is
just you could tell i guess why they
didn't release it because it is
sycophantic
to an extreme even for cnn it is
embarrassing
the to call it a puff piece for
alexandria case or cortez would would
way understate the case
this would it was like it's like
something that alexandria case or
cortez's campaign would put together
only this was cnn to put together they
said not to release it project veritas
they got their hands on it they did
release it
and uh there's one claim that alexandria
casa cortez made
during this interview with dana bash
from cnn that i think is especially
notable
here it is that attack on the capitol
you know white supremacy and patriarchy
are very linked in a lot of ways there's
a lot of
sexualizing of that violence
and um i didn't think that i was just
going to be killed i thought other
things were going to happen to me as
well
so what sounds like what you're telling
me right now is that you didn't
only think that you were going to die
you thought you were going to be raped
yeah right well
alexandra casey cortez to remind you
was not in the capitol building that day
she wasn't in the building where this
was happening she never personally
encountered
any rioters her physical safety
was not in jeopardy it wasn't
she was not in the building
there was a troubling thing happening in
a building nearby
not her own building
and now she said we already know that
she had just this elaborate story
of how her life was in jeopardy
she thought she was going to be killed
even though there was nobody in the
building coming after her
and then the police officer and this
these again are the newly reformed back
the blue democrats and yet this one
said that the through the police officer
came to help her
or from from her perspective rescue her
even though her her safety was not in
jeopardy
police officer came to help her um she
threw
that guy under the bus so she didn't
like his attitude
she felt unsafe around him
and that was bad enough and now she says
she's afraid that she was going to be
raped
this is grotesque this is
emotional manipulation
to an extreme that that almost manages
to shock you
maybe it doesn't quite make it to that
point because this is
aoc we're talking about the very
beginning of her
national political career she goes down
to the border
and poses for instagram shots crying in
front of an empty parking lot
so that's the kind of person we're
dealing with here
but this goes way beyond that this is
monstrous
for her to throw that out there
that is monstrous
from this this woman here
horrific all right um
and if if you really cared about sexual
abuse
survivors you wouldn't be
throwing something like this out there
using it so
flippantly
okay this is from cnbc moving on says
the centers for disease control and
prevention recommended on tuesday that
fully vaccinated people begin wearing
masks
indoors again in places with high cover
19 transmission rates
the agency is also recommending kids
wear masks in school this fall federal
health officials still believe fully
vaccinated individuals
represent a very small amount of
transmission still some vaccinated
people
could be carrying higher levels of the
virus than previously understood and
potentially transmitted to others
the updated guidance comes ahead of the
fall season when the highly contagious
delta variant is expected to cause
another surge um
and uh this wellenski says well actually
we have the clip of wolinski talking
about this so i guess we'll just play
that here's cdc director
rochelle wolenski talking about why you
might need to start wearing a mask again
here it is
in areas with substantial and high
transmission
cdc recommends fully vaccinated people
wear masks in public indoor settings
to help prevent the spread of the delta
variant and protect
others this includes school
cdc recommends that everyone in k-12
schools
wear a mask indoors including teachers
staff students and visitors regardless
of vaccination status
children should return to full-time
in-person learning
in the fall with proper prevention
strategies in place
so this we're talking about not just um
in schools well that too that might be
the worst part of this
it's it's being demanded now that uh
kids
wear masks in school so we're not gonna
be
know the kids will not get there they
get to finally just go to school like
normal human beings they got to wear
masks the entire day
um but also based on the cdc's guidance
it sounds like what they're saying
is that you should be wearing a mask
even in your own home
if you if you live in an area with uh
with
high rates of of covid and you live with
people
who are not vaccinated then you should
be wearing a mask around people that
aren't vaccinated which
presumably would include your own home
that's what the cdc is saying uh and
we're gonna start to see we've already
we have already seen but we'll begin to
see even more
um these mandates being put in
into effect on on local and and state
levels
the question is really just whether you
will choose
to abide by it um
and and if you do
you know i go back to the sam adams
quote
if you love wealth better than liberty
the tranquility of servitude better than
the animating contest of freedom go home
from us in peace
we ask not your counsel or arms crouch
down and lick the hands
which feed you may your chains set
lightly upon you
and may posterity forget that you are
our countrymen that's
that's where that's where i am now with
the mask
may your mask set lightly upon you
and may posterity forget that you are
our countryman i don't even want to
share a country with you
you're a disgrace
if you're still taking these people
seriously
after all of this
you're going to do what they tell you to
do
contradicting themselves constantly
let's be clear about something the data
haven't changed here there's been no
scientific breakthrough that's changed
our understanding of the virus
okay we're seeing an uptick in cases in
some parts of the country
these things kind of happening in waves
that's not a surprise
we knew that was going to happen that's
always going to happen
because covid like the flu is
never going to go away it's always going
to be around most likely
we are going to have to live with it
or refuse to live because of it that's
the choice here
but that part we knew um
as far as the risk that it poses to
vaccinated people which is almost
non-existent
you know your your chance of getting
seriously sick from covid
if you're vaccinated or if you have uh
immunity from from prior infection which
by the way is another thing you notice
we're not even talking about that
we don't talk about natural immunity at
least the media doesn't it doesn't come
up
the white house they don't talk about it
the cdc doesn't talk about it
does that mean that it doesn't exist no
it does there have been studies done on
this
natural immunity from covet is a real
thing
and it gives according to studies it
gives um
and this is this work this this comports
with with common sense
again what you would expect it does
gives you it does give you
lasting and significant protection
from getting infected again so
we we always hear about the number of
people who have been vaccinated which is
100 whatever
plus 60 million whatever it is um
there's also a signifi the when it comes
to the unvaccinated's
the unclean stay away right um
the the people which i guess should be
in leper colonies now
of that group a certain
not insignificant portion of them also
have immunity
because they've already had it
so you've got many many adults already
vaccinated
the vast majority of people in the high
risk groups are vaccinated
um elderly people people with
comorbidities
uh uh peop obese you know these
high-risk categories they got vaccinated
early on so the vascularium are
vaccinated
um most adults are vaccinated already
of the people who are not vaccinate a
great number of them have
immunity from prior infection and then
of the people who have no prior immunity
and are not vaccinated
a great number of them are kids who from
the very beginning we've always known
are not at any serious risk of the virus
and also just young adults in general
who also are not at any serious risk
so who are we trying to protect right
now who are
these people who are at serious risk
from the virus
and don't have any kind of immunity at
all either vax either from vaccination
or natural immunity
how many fall into that category like 10
i don't know
um but these are just normal common
sense
observations and questions
uh and if if you are not thinking about
this stuff right now
and you're gonna follow these people
right rochelle walensky and these
quote-unquote public health experts if
you're going to follow them around like
a blind dog
on a leash then i i don't know what to
do for you
i don't know what to say to you other
than fine
yeah but go ahead be a dog be a dog get
let around on a leash
let them put the muzzle on you
maybe it's a good thing now really
separating the wheat from the chaff
really showing us who is who
to wear the mask now it's like this this
is like the scarlet letter
i mean it is showing is showing us who
you who you are
and how much we should should or should
not respect you
okay um let's see what else do we got
here
uh do we have time uh okay i wanted to
mention
this this is from cnn ashton kutcher and
mila kunis
appeared on an episode of dak shepard's
armchair expert podcast
and the talk turned to bathing after
shepard told co-host monica padman
that using soap every day rids the body
of natural oils kutcher and kunis agreed
saying they only wash vitals every day
so they don't bathe and they don't bathe
their kids
okay wait a second i'm trying to figure
out why i read this story to you i was
trying to
and one other thing i wanted to tell you
about before i move on to reading the
comments and daily cancellation i
decided to go with this
mila kunis and ashley kutcher's poor
hygiene why did i do that i don't know
why why was cnn reporting it
why is any of this happening who am i
who are you where am i
i don't have nobody will ever know i
don't have the answer to any of those
questions i will say since we're on the
subject
on the topic of bathing um i believe in
bathing
i put me in the pro bathing camp um but
i do think that this
here's as far as i'll go in their
direction i do think that the soap
industry
is scamming us i think i think there's
kind of a conspiracy and i've always
thought this
big soap okay there's kind of a
conspiracy there and they have convinced
us especially women
to buy like 15 different versions of
soap
you know the average american bathroom
now the average american bathroom has in
and of itself
15 different versions of soap and then
you've got different soaps in the
kitchen different soaps for everything
my theory which i have not
tested in a laboratory setting is that
really
all soap is the same and you only need
one kind for all applications
it's it's soap a soap am i
suggesting
that you should potentially bathe with
dishwashing liquid and use that for
everything yeah
again not not a tested assertion but
that's my theory
okay moving on to reading youtube
comments this is from chris he says
does your poison position to the drug
argument also apply to alcohol
in my opinion it should um
also have you spilled out all of your
blantons yet
okay we were talking about drugs
yesterday and uh and the legalization of
drugs and
yes someone someone said well we should
have the right to ingest whatever we
want
and my point was yeah you can ingest
whatever you want whether you have the
legal right or not you can nobody can
stop you
from from ingesting anything you can as
i said you could get a bottle of
gasoline and drink it i don't recommend
it but you could no one can really stop
you from doing it
um the question is yeah yeah you can
ingest any poison you want
but should people have the right to sell
you any poison that they want to sell
you and my answer to that is
no they shouldn't and how do you decide
you know
what should be illegal what shouldn't
what should be what you should be
allowed to sell what you shouldn't be
allowed to sell
well i would say we could start with
this and i and i know that it can get a
little more complicated
as we get into the kind of gray areas
but
certainly to begin with if something is
simply
poison and it can do nothing but harm
you
and kill you then that is not something
that should be legal to sell
uh and a lot of drugs a lot of the
currently illegal drugs fall into that
category not all of them
um as i said there's a gray area though
we can talk about marijuana there's a
gray area there
uh now i did get a lot of comments
saying what about alcohol
well no alcohol is not poison it's not
taken in a moderate dose it can have in
fact positive physical effects
certainly it can be and there have been
many studies in fact there was a recent
study that i just had now
now i've lost sight of it but yahoo news
was reporting maybe i could find it
um okay their headline light to moderate
drinking tied to lower risk of heart
attack
and death in patients with heart disease
so we've seen a lot of studies like this
and every once all you'll see a study on
the other side saying no
no actually it doesn't help but um
that's a live question anyway i think
i think at least reasonably we can say
at a minimum
that drinking in moderation for most
people is not going to hurt you
um and there's a very good chance that
in fact it could help you
so that's why alcohol is different it it
is it's it is not poison
it can become poisonous if you choose to
way overdo it but then again
any substance can potentially become
poisonous
if you overdo it water you could die
from drinking too much water water
poisoning is a thing
nobody would say that it should be
illegal to sell water bottled water
uh so i don't think alcohol falls into
that category something like crack
cocaine for example
does i mean that's that can do there is
no moderate level of crack cocaine usage
there is no level at which it won't
really hurt you or potentially could
help you
physically it is simply poison straight
up and uh it shouldn't be legal
to sell um
another comment says the fishing tackle
comment was brilliant i organized my
baking ingredients yesterday
good job though i say so myself there is
a certain joy
in organizing items that you uh like to
use
and that isn't a joy that can only be
experienced once you're old and boring
it is for kids the kids are horrified to
think that they'll
get to a point when they would actually
enjoy
organizing fishing tackle or baking
ingredients
or a sock drawer but it will happen to
you it will
unless you die before that that's the
only thing that'll save you
and let's see
bob says nice matt you're saying that
turtles the turtle's family
didn't care about him because he's
disabled i'm glad i'm banned from
watching
no the turtle's family my kids the
disabled turtle that they rescue
they abandon them okay they're the
deadbeats we rescued that turtle from an
abusive situation
or else we kidnapped him when his
parents were just a few feet away
and we didn't notice that's also
possible but who really knows
and finally joppa says i'm uncomfortable
calling matt sweet daddy walsh probably
because i'm old enough to be matt's
daddy
well joe pop please do not deadname me
my name is sweet daddy walsh that's how
i identify
and i i expect you to respect that ben
shapiro's new book the authoritarian
moment has
finally hit bookshelves and it's time
for you to read up on some truth ben's
book
covers an in-depth look at how the left
has taken control over
our institutions entertainment education
centers our relationships
everything for example um our great
nation's leader is entertaining the idea
of requiring vaccines
for all federal employees in fact i
think i think i think
that that actually has come down and
that will be required in addition the
cdc is now recommending that all
vaccinated folks
still wear masks as we talked about and
gavin newsom is the first to adopt that
it's it's unbelievable the authoritarian
lengths
that these politicians will go are
willing to go just to enforce
their brand of order and that's what the
authoritarian moment
is all about that's why it could not be
more timely
for this moment the authoritarian moment
is now available amazon barnes noble or
any other major bookseller so you can
get your copy now and
leave a five-star review to help amplify
conservative voices
and also speaking of amplifying
conservative voices you'll hear some
conservative voices tonight for
another episode of backstage always very
exciting you can join me ben shapiro
jeremy bohr michael knowles andrew
clavin
and candace owens will be there for an
extra exciting cigar pack session of
backstage it streams tonight at seven
o'clock
eastern 6 p.m central on dailywire.com
and on our youtube channel dailywire
don't miss it and for a limited time you
can enter to win at backstage vip pass
to visit the
daily wire studios meet your backstage
hosts
myself included i don't know why you
would want to meet me exactly
um but you can and i'll stand there
staring at you awkwardly hopefully the
other guys will do most of talking
you also get a swag bag of daily wire
merchandise including autographed books
new daily wire members are automatically
entered to win so go to dailywire.com
subscribe i like how they did they
didn't ask me about this do you want to
be involved in this
no you were just i'm like a zoo animal
people are coming just stand there in
your natural environment
and let them gawk at you anyway um go to
dailywire.com
subscribe get 25 off a new membership
with code backstage now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
as previously noted yesterday was a big
day for performatively emotional
displays by hen-pect men
during the january 6th hearing uh one
man after another took turns bawling his
eyes out
weeping openly and without shame the
most grotesque and nauseating spectacles
came as always from the politicians
here is representative adam schiff
getting choked up for
unclear reasons we deem elections
illegitimate merely because they didn't
go our way
rather than trying to do better the next
time god help us
and if we're so driven by bigotry and
hate that we attack our fellow citizens
as traitors
if they're born another country or they
don't look like us
and
god help us but
i have faith
because of folks like you and uh
adam i didn't expect this would be quite
so much leader but it must be an adam
thing today
uh but i'm so grateful to all of you
and with that mr sherman i yield back uh
he's got to work on his acting a little
bit
i appreciate the timing so he timed his
emotional breakdown for
when he mentioned bigotry now that's
when he's
oh we have to be nicer to people who
don't look like
us it's bigotry's
so upsetting to me um so he
he he timed it well but i the the acting
needs a little bit of work he wasn't the
only adam to carry on this way adam
kinzinger a republican
sobbed even louder it was an inspiring
moment
of bipartisan emasculation let's watch
that
thank you mr chairman and uh thank you
to my colleagues on the committee
thank you to our witnesses uh i never
expected a day to be
quite as emotional for me as it has been
i've talked to
a number of you and gotten to know you
i think it's important to tell you right
now though
you guys may like individually feel a
little broken
you guys all talk about the effects you
have to deal with and
you know you talk about the impact of
that day
but you guys won
you guys held
you know democracies are not defined
by our bad days
we're defined by how we come back from
bad bad days
how we take accountability for that
and for all the overheated rhetoric
surrounding this committee
our mission is very simple let's define
the truth and it's to ensure
accountability
sorry i'm getting a little emotional too
a little misty-eyed now it goes without
saying that neither of these men have
shed any tears as we discussed earlier
for any of the victims of any of the
horrific blm riots last year
police officers were bashed over the
head with bricks beat attacked berated
this is all on video uh their precincts
were burned to the ground a retired
police officer was murdered in cold
blood and left for dead in the street
neither of the crying adams have
ever shed any tears for those officers
by the way that should be a band name
the crying adams
that's because their tears are fake and
manipulative fake and manipulative tears
from anyone are disgraceful but from a
man
even more so even leaving aside the rank
dishonesty here
this is also part of a larger problem a
symptom
of an endemic disease the fact that
grown men will now
cry to get what they want like my
eight-year-old daughter
only shows again that masculinity is in
a dire state in this culture
there was a time when that sort of
display would have been considered
embarrassing and weak but now we're
meant to take a man seriously when he
cries in front of us
even more seriously if anything i think
this is wrong to put him mildly
and i've said so many times i reiterated
this point on twitter yesterday
this is what i wrote simply i said men
should not cry in public it is unmanly
and dishonorable rare exceptions can be
made to this rule
but we make far too many exceptions and
the exceptions are pretty obvious
a loved one dies your child is born your
bride is walking down the aisle at your
wedding
in the latter two cases a dignified tier
or two may be acceptable but please
don't turn the faucet on
okay there's no reason to go overboard
don't try to prove a point
um other exceptions can be imagined
we've talked about some of them before
perhaps for example
you're saying goodbye to your family
before embarking on a three-year voyage
to mars
maybe you're watching the end of the
movie rudy aside from those rare
occurrences
the point is that men should comport
themselves with a certain level of
stoicism
and dignity learning to control their
emotions and projecting an image of
strength
of someone who is composed and in
control
yeah it's possible to go overboard to go
overboard in that direction
becoming an emotionless robot entirely
unaffected by suffering your own or
anyone else's
but there aren't very many men in our
society who are at any risk of falling
into that trap
the problem in most cases lies way at
the other end of the spectrum
men today are encouraged to put their
emotions on display at all times to be
vulnerable
to be soft and feminine and gentle
men are encouraged to be women in other
words in fact
some of the responses to my tweet were
pretty enlightening lots of people
of course were scoffing at the opinion
that i expressed even though it's an
opinion
shared by most people in the world
whether they'll say it out loud or not
most women naturally want a man who will
comfort them
when they cry they don't want to be
doing most of the comforting
i'm not a woman myself so i will allow
the ladies to correct me on this point
but i can't imagine that most single
women are searching for the kind of man
who will break down in tears at the
slightest disappointment or setback
few women i'm guessing dream of the sort
of man who will come home from work
tears dripping down his cheeks sobbing
and saying
i just had a really bad day hank at the
office was super rude
i am so frustrated i would also theorize
that the typical
woman wouldn't marry a man at all if she
knew that he'd be the type
to shake her awake in the middle of the
night teary-eyed and trembling and
saying
i just heard a noise outside can you go
out and check i'm so scared
few women want men who are like this few
boys want to grow into men like this
and yet our culture produces men like
this
this may not be something that the
average person desires but it is the
agenda all the same
an agenda shared by for example a woman
named rachel barabo
uh she's not any great cultural force by
any means but she is a former
sportscaster turned it seems into some
kind of motivational speaker for
students and young men
i know of her existence because she
tweeted at me in response to my thoughts
about men crying and she said
two words shut up yep
i've got my sassy pants on today we are
changing the narrative on what
masculinity means
despite what this guy says
now again this is not any any any kind
of a person of any great importance but
there is something so apt about this
here is a woman who likely doesn't
represent the views of most women we
should know
but a woman all the same telling me a
man
to shut up on the subject of masculinity
and to defer to her expertise
she not only a woman but a person who
uses the phrase
sassy pants has decided that she should
be in charge
of changing the narrative on masculinity
as for me a man a husband a father of
four
i have to pipe down and allow her to
dictate terms
sadly many men have decided to obey
these kinds of demands from these kinds
of women
our culture has indeed allowed women to
take the lead even to the extent of
defining masculinity
we see this in our schools and our
churches in hollywood and media
we live in an increasingly feminine
world though ironically men are once
again reasserting their dominance
by identifying as women and bringing
everything full circle it is a confused
situation to say the least
now into this confusion as a way of
clearing the fog a little bit i'd like
to offer
a clarifying image of what masculinity
is actually supposed to be
and how it is supposed to act in the
world this is a story i've mentioned a
couple of times on the show but it's
worth mentioning again
um in in this uh situation it comes from
sergeant easton's uh
gulag archipelago his magnum opus about
the soviet labor camp system
in one of the volumes volume one i
believe he recounts the story of a man
who had been arrested on trumped-up
charges and shipped off to prison
and when he was at prison he was
sentenced to death but by the time the
sentence had been handed down his wife
was already on a boat
on the way to visit him and so he begged
the guards to delay his execution for a
few days so that he could
see his wife one last time they agreed
on the condition
that he doesn't tell her about his
impending execution
and he didn't he was with her for three
days never mentioned it
never hinted at it uh and once she left
he was taken immediately before the
firing squad and shot
now that is stoicism and manliness
beyond the capacity of most mere mortals
but
it points us in in the direction that we
should be striving towards
we are meant as men to carry our burdens
with dignity
and not to expect everyone else least of
all the women in our lives
to lighten our loads by always sharing
in them
that at least is one way to be a man
the other is adam schiff weeping like a
school girl
using his tears to manipulate and
exploit
you could choose that option if you want
but you have to sacrifice your dignity
and your masculinity
and your self-respect in the process
and also you are today for that reason
canceled and we'll leave it there thanks
for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pablo vadosky the
show is edited by sasha tulmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 2021.
john bickley here editor-in-chief of
daily wire wake up every morning with
our new show
morning wire on today's show the
floodgates open on vaccine mandates the
refund the police movement gains
momentum
and troops withdraw from the middle east
join us
and get the facts first on the news you
need to know with our show
morning wire